こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです。
あいつもそろそろ気づくと思うんだよね
俺んちに来ると何かしらのドッキリをされるって事は
多分もうあいつは分かってるかもしれない
みなさんは
よく見ませんか？
大体ね、パターンはもう決まっちゃってるんよ
もうパターンは決まってる
てかもうこのパターンしかないってくらいねぇ、あの
ボールペンですね。
ボールペンを、この、カチッってやったら
ビリビリッってきて、
はあ！！…………もぉ〜。
テンテン(終わり風に)
ってパターンがめちゃくちゃ多い。
甘い！！
実に甘い！
電気ショックドッキリっていうのは
もう、ボールペンぐらいしかないとしか僕は思ってたんですけども、
僕は見つけてしまいました。
こちら。これは僕のiphoneではありません。
こっちが普通の僕のiphoneなんですけど
どうかな？
結構ね、ちゃんと作り込んであるんですよ。
ぱっと見ね、かなりクオリティは高いんですよ。
ちょっとこういうカメラとかの所は
作りが甘いので、これじゃバレちまう。
このホームボタンを押すと
超強力な電流が流れます。
このままやっちゃうとバレちゃうので、
これ、わざわざ、もう、
このドッキリのために買ってきましたからね。
iphone6+用のiphoneケースです。
多分、サイズ的にiphone6+なんすよ。
ドッキリにかける情熱が違うわ。
ていう訳でこれを付けていきましょう。
ぴったりでしょ。
あ？あれ？
あ、OK。ギリ入る。ギリ入る。
OK。ちょっと怪しいかな？
ちょっと怪しいんですけど、なんとか入りました。
という訳で、これ。ここを押すと
電流が流れます。
ちょっと試しに、試しにやってみましょう。
あ〜、これ本当は、本当強いんですよ。
ちょっと待って。
ヤダ、ヤダ。
うわー！！
やるしかない。
やっぱね、テストで受けないとダメだから。
あれ？あれ？
壊れちゃった？あれ？
あれ？点かなくなっちゃった。
あ！イテテ！痛っ！痛っ！痛っ！痛っ！痛っ！
これ、なんだ？ケース付けたら、なんなかった
電気通さないからかなぁ。あれ？
ケース付けたらなんないぞ。ケース付けたらなんない。
痛ァ！！
待って！本当に痛い…。
金属部分のここがなんか関係してんのかな？
ここがなんか封じられてると、電気が流れないみたいです。
買った意味。
どうやって出そうかな。
「ロック画面見てみて」のこういう感じで渡したほうが自然です。
これでいこう。
渡して持てば、多分普通に押せば…。
イテ！
待って！本当に、本当に強いからね！
え、待って！失神とかしないよね？
みなさんじゃわかりづらいと思うんですけど、
めちゃくちゃ強いです。
さすがに騙せると思います。
「iphone、変えたんだ〜。」って言って
「ちょっとロック画面見てよ」って渡して
ポチッっと押した瞬間、
早速セットしていきましょう。
では、行こう。
では、早速迎えに行ってきます。
バイバイ。
行ってきます。
おいしょー。
いや、今日はドッキリしないよ。
今日はしねーよ。
今日はさすがにしないよ。
あ〜、ありがとです。
ご飯食べた？
まさき「食べてない。」
ねえ、新しいiphone、買った。
まさき「え？」
ちょっとロック画面、見て。
(ビリビリッ)
まさき「うぉぉぉー！」
(はじめしゃちょー爆笑)
(はじめしゃちょー大爆笑)
やったー！
まさき「しないって言ったじゃん！！」
結構痛くなかった？
まさき「びっくりしたよ、今」